in the 17th century ham house
in southwest London belonged to the
wealthy Duchess of Lauderdale the story
goes that her presence is still very
much felt and Partington manages the
property the Duchess was ruthless and
ambitious and made sure that she got
what she wanted she was the daughter of
a man called William Murray who was a
royalist supporter to Charles at first
the Duchess died at the house after a
long illness but curiously after 300
years
visitors are convinced she hasn't left
people see things and this there's a
long description of the house being a
dark and gloomy having visitors to the
house other than that those who live
here and it's long been believed it's a
DEP chess who walks the corridors in the
house Anne has lived in the house for a
couple of years she says she was first
skeptical about the stories but now has
her own personal experience of ghostly
goings-on I personally have heard and
I've smelt things I've never seen
anything I've never seen a figure and as
other people have claimed seeing and but
I've heard steps and people staying with
me I've heard people walking up and down
that great stairs or the Duchess is
meant to be which leads up to my floor
and they said I can hear something
walking up the stairs
and never come in but I know the alarms
are set and I know that nobody could be
walking up those stairs and they also
claim they can smell her perfume which
was rose perfume over the years ghost
hunters have visited ham house in the
hope of witnessing the hauntings
firsthand amateur ghost investigator
Josh smaller is fascinated by the
stories of the Dutchess this would be a
room that certainly has got
possibilities of her paranormal activity
I've been in rooms where things have
happened which I can't explain
rationally rooms where I've set up my
slate and chalk the rooms been left
empty for 90 minutes or so I've returned
to the room and something has been
written on the slate tonight the ghost
hunter will be disappointed the Dutchess
is not going to perform for his camera
whether or not there's any truth in the
stories he'll never know bizarrely as he
left for the night there was a distinct
smell of roses that he couldn't explain
and so for the moment ham house remains
a mystery
its ghostly secrets still intact